it can have a very not necessarily
oppressive but kind of weighty presence
on you my relationship with her an Asian
can sometimes be a little complicated
being Asian informs most of my identity
sometimes I will identify as Asian but
then other Indian people don't identify
as Asian why are you considered Asian
here in the Pacific Islander and
wouldn't you be considered more Hawaiian
and I'm like not really I have this
awareness that it's the first thing that
people notice about me people associate
Asian with East Asian Filipinos aren't
so much dismissed they're just
overlooked just because they're not as
popular within at least the American
culture if you think about it the world
population sixty percent of it is
technically Asians and we don't speak of
any ethnic group at large on such a
continental scale Asia as a term refers
to a continent of like 40 to 50
different countries all with really
really differently history culture
language religion but the term Asian has
utility it's just within that there is
so much diversity that needs to be
acknowledged and especially when you
extend that to Pacific Islanders
people will say things like oh that's so
Asian or like why are you being so Asian
or like stop being so Asian and I'm like
I'm just trying to eat my lunch here
like I don't notice that why my lunch
makes like says that being so Asian even
when I did my hair this morning I was
like oh every time I put my hair in a
bun
do I look too Asian but what does that
even mean because I am Asian in high
school I had to deal a lot with the
stereotype of being Asian and smart
other people would say oh you just did
well because you're Asian yes I am you
know I'm proud of it but my first
identifying like features should not be
like oh that guy's Asian so therefore
he's this isn't this it's the way
they're saying the word and it's not the
word itself
the biggest source of pride for me is
whenever I see fellow Asians and Asian
Americans making their voices heard I
have incorporated my love of India into
the work that I do my mom has a
signature Filipino like bloom via a
girls I always bring map and that was my
way of kind of like introducing people
to phil-billy culture I think I feel
like the reason that I am always
staunchly proud of being Pacific
Islander specifically is to kind of
raise awareness just on a personal level
your identity informs everything that
you do and that's something to be
celebrated it's something to be excited
about no matter what you're able to
identify as Asian and you're able to
understand some this journey if we're
able to see Asia and Asian American as
like a group and as a conversation we
can use something like that as a way to
collectively reza